welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
in this video we're going to be breaking
down the second episode of the undoing
now as always the show starts with the
song dream a little dream
being sung by nicole kidman i did say in
the last review that
i thought this was her but didn't know
for definite however we now have it
confirmed that kidman is indeed behind
this song
and she has the voice of an angel
uh no now the second entry itself picks
up with jonathan still missing and the
episode very much
centers around grace being put through
the ringer as police tried to get to the
bottom of what happened
we opened with grace just getting off
the phone to the other jonathan that she
called last week
and as mentioned last time this person
having the same name as her husband
also metaphorically symbolizes the
duality that he possesses
throughout we learn what really happened
with him in eleanor
and it's revealed that jonathan was
indeed living a double life
in rat respect there were several clues
that hinted towards this two-sidedness
and quite a lot actually packed in the
first episode now firstly
grace took a therapy session with a
woman who said that her husband was
bipolar
she said that he had two sides to him
and later in the episode
grace also took a session with two men
that were in a relationship together
there are also two men in her immediate
family two policemen investigating the
crime
and though this isn't really hitting us
over the head with the symbolism
i think this idea of double-sidedness is
laced throughout the show
as mentioned earlier there was a phone
call with the fake jonathan
and the fact that he appeared as a
doctor nursing a sick child in one of
grace's dreams
also brings a lot with it the theme tune
is of course dream a little dream of me
which talks about the perfect life and
grace and jonathan even discussed at one
point how their son lived in a bubble
which grace clearly did too now one of
the interesting aspects of the first
episode
is that jonathan at one point scoffed at
the school fundraiser
because he was annoyed that they were
already paying quite a lot
shortly after we learned that it was in
fact grace's father who was paying for
henry's education
and it seems like something you would
probably know if you were paying or not
now shout outs to terra cotta kim on our
last video for suggesting that the child
of eleanor may actually be jonathan's
and this could be where the confusion
came about if the baby is indeed
jonathan's kid
then eleanor may have blackmailed him
into paying for her oldest son's
education
and thus this is why he got confused
over paying money towards the school
at the end of the entry we discover that
she did use jonathan to pull some
strings to get a kid in
but i think it goes far beyond that now
we also discover that elena's husband
wants to take a paternity test
so all signs do point towards jonathan
being the father
now i realize i'm talking a hell of a
lot about the first episode
but i think in retrospect all of the
clues were there to point towards the
reveal that jonathan
indeed had another side to his life
turns out he was lying to grace about
his job
and what was really going on with
eleanor we discovered that the pair
became close while stuart's son was
being treated at his hospital
and because of their relationship he was
eventually fired
elena ended up becoming obsessed with
him and then grace
and this is why she acted the way that
she did in the first episode
after the events of the fundraiser
jonathan left the party and went to meet
her
and not long after she was murdered now
he flat out denies having anything to do
with her death
and when he and grace come face to face
he simply says that he found her like
that
which i'm sure i'm sure that'll hold up
in court mate definitely go with that
one
now he stupidly ran away and in the
episode the cross has closed
in on grace and she's even taken in for
police questioning
at one point now the police clearly knew
more than she did
and they likely learned from the
hospital all the ins and outs of his
employment
and interactions with eleanor initially
they hold back information
and come to grace in the form of two
guys that just want to have a chat
we discovered that they are hiding stuff
and actually know the truth about
jonathan
and thus when it's revealed grace storms
out of the interrogation
this duality and false persona is also
mirrored in her friends and the
headmaster when she drops henry off at
school for the second time
the head in the first episode initially
came across as a really nice man
as did the committee at rioden however
we see the other side of them in this
entry
now it was hinted at in the past and not
to go over my first breakdown again too
much
but there was a comment at the
fundraiser in which they said the
teachers were amazing
but we know that they didn't get invited
to the party eleanor was the only person
in the entry that seemed to be willing
to bear all
literally and when she did this grace's
friends scoffed and discussed behind the
scenes
even though at the time they all seemed
fine with it
now grace too did say in the car on the
way to the auction
that it was too far which juxtaposed how
she acted to elna's face
and we get the feeling here that grace
may too be dealing with her own feelings
of a double side to her personality
when she looks in the mirror at one
point she sees elena's face staring back
at her
and when she goes and sits down on the
bed shortly after
we also see her reflection in two
mirrors i love how this motif of two is
laced throughout the episode
and i think the creative team do an
outstanding job of portraying the way
that the characters are
through little hints like this now
another big hint that
i might be reading into too much happens
when grace first drops off henry at
school
sylvia played by lily rabe is discussing
with the committee
how eleanor's husband handed himself
into the police
she says and i quote of course it was
the husband
first he vanished then he hands himself
in
although she is talking about elna's
husband with the context of jonathan
added to it
this could indeed hint that he has
committed the crime
then decided to vanish and is going to
hand himself in
i think this could be you know the plot
for episode three
and now grace is the one who grasses
them up to the police
it does sort of lean towards that and
i'm sorry you know what i just realized
how much i'm reaching this entire video
apologies for for that and all the times
i've said two
second and duality unless you like it of
course
in which case shut the hell up and stop
complaining anyway
none of this may be intentional but i
think that the show is so well written
that things like this really stand out
in the episode we also get more
interactions between grace and her
father
played by donald sutherland on our last
video designs to the nines dropped a
really great comment about what the
economic situation is like in new york
and this provided a lot more context to
things that i didn't know about
the user said that a fully renovated
apartment in the upper east side of
manhattan
costs in the millions and that grace and
jonathan's salary would likely not cover
it
thus we can gather it's grace's father
who probably paid for it
alongside henry's education we also see
that the family have a beach house that
grace retreats to
and these costs are really starting to
mount up i think it's going to be
interesting to see what happens between
her father and jonathan
as i think they're just going to be
butting heads at some point
further in the series now grace has a
private conversation with sylvia
in which they go over the ins and outs
of what's really going on with jonathan
we learned that he hired her as a lawyer
in order to give him advice
now we could actually go beyond this and
i think that it may be possible that
sylvia is the one that killed eleanor
and that she's also obsessed with grace
that doesn't happen in the book
but learning that she knew the ins and
outs of what was going on with jonathan
and also dropped the hint earlier in the
entry does tease that she knows a lot
more than she should
she likely knows that jonathan will be
implicated in the murder as well
and tells grace that if she comes across
him to tell the police immediately
this is because she knows they will pin
the crime on him instantly
due to the character being absent from
the party and there's definitely a
possibility
that she's behind it i have absolutely
nothing to back that up at the moment if
i'm being honest
and you know what it's it's my editor's
theory so yeah if it doesn't come true
bloody blame him anyway after the police
search her house and the truth gets too
much for her
grace goes to their home by the sea this
is where she comes face to face with
jonathan
who's likely been hiding out here since
he disappeared
i'm not gonna lie when he ran up and
grabbed her mouth i did crop my pants a
bit
anyway he plays up ellen as mental
health and says that she became obsessed
over him
before moving on to grace oh i wish she
was obsessed over me
god damn now after the party we learned
that he went to her and tried to get her
to back off
but they ended up having sex so probably
didn't go that well now
after this he went for a walk and then
to a bar
and came back and found her dead
is it believable i don't know now i
might have the book looming over my head
a bit too much but a lot of these
reveals don't actually come until much
later in the work
and thus i think that the show might be
diverting from the source material quite
a bit
i just feel like jonathan being behind
it is so obvious
that i'm not sure if it could even be
the case
either way we end with grace calling the
police
shopping her husband in and as we know
snitches gets stitches
anyway that concludes the episode and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it as well as what your theories are
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of the best easter
eggs in lovecraft country which is going
to be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also become chapters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
you